montevideo tiene un aroma especial la
capital uruguaya respira más fútbol que
nunca y estos turistas dan fe de la
reactivación que llega a la ciudad con
el deporte rey son hinchas de atlético
paranaense el conjunto que este sábado
se medirá a bragantino los equipos
brasileños que se disputan la copa
sudamericana y protagonizan la primera
de tres finales en una semana tienen la
ilusión de levantar el título pero
lamentan el costo de la experiencia
mucha gente por eso creo que los precios
fueron muy altos y
acá también las cosas no están muy
baratas para los otros brasileños han
sido 20 meses de cierre en uruguay el
país abrió el primero de noviembre sus
fronteras a los turistas vacunados o que
presenten pruebas negativas de kobe 19
en esta ocasión el gobierno confía en
que los aficionados del fútbol que
lleguen dejen unos 30 millones de
dólares en recaudación número que
aplauden desde el sector hotelero ahora
está hablando alrededor de 60.000
personas que vienen
eso más lo que va a movilizar
internamente en el país la verdad que es
algo muy pero muy positivo y es un
empujón muy importante que lo que hace
es mitigar el impacto económico que
venimos teniendo en el año 2020 el
parque central será la sede de la final
de la copa libertadores femenina este
domingo 21 de noviembre entre
corinthians e independiente santafé el
mítico estadio centenario recibe la
final de la copa sudamericana este
sábado y la gran final de la copa
libertadores masculina el 27 de
noviembre entre flamengo y palmeiras
todos los tres eventos sin límite de
aforo una fiesta del fútbol de camino a
la gloria eterna